hey guys for this video I'm going to
take a more positive look at Game of
Thrones season 8 since the anniversary
just passed I missed it because I was
just you know binging something else I
owe it to Game of Thrones to take off
the brass knuckles since I've made so
many videos bashing it and actually take
a look at what season 8 did well I'm
going to go into everything story wise
that the season did right obviously they
did a great job with the music and VFX
as an example but for this video I'll be
prioritizing what happens in the show
there's a lot of things that this season
did alright but I'll be pointing out
what I think they did a good job on
Liana Morman
out of all the characters that had
unsatisfying payoffs and were ruined
Lyanna Mormont surprisingly had a great
payoff she initially gets heated off the
screen like a fly and you're like for
[ __ ] sake did they just kill a fan
favorite and like half a second but no
she comes back in those badass way
possible and takes down a giant the
hound
to be honest all they have to do is have
him roast people and it's already a plus
television the Lord Allah is gonna
wonder why I brought you back 19 times
just to watch you die when I took you
over this [ __ ] wall but besides him
just roasting people they go into the
arc of how the Hound is being more
sympathetic they perfectly pay it off by
saving Arya from killing yourself for
vengeance which is the very thing that
consumes Sandor Clegane cleganebowl
although this was very cheesy it gave us
some very epic and funny moments the
funny one being Kai burns death I can
still watch that mo in and laugh because
it's so stupid that it's good but yeah
the whole scene is epic and fun the
awesome set-piece the slow build of the
draw of the swords the reveal of what
the mountain looks like the epic fight
big chunga's great editing character
payoffs what more could he ask for the
destruction of King's Landing
although the motivation for Daenerys
destroying King's Landing was horribly
executed the destruction of King's
Landing itself was still really well
done they always mentioned how dragons
leveled cities like with Tywin talking
to Arya harren and all his sons roasted
alive with
these wounds but now we actually get to
see it in all its glory
also having arias point of view gives
you a real sense of how much chaos is
unfolding in the city without her
perspective giving more depth to this
scenario they would have just been pure
spectacle
samwell meeting Daenerys this was
surprisingly one of the best scenes in
episode one that we didn't even know we
needed Sam Oh being humbled and getting
to meet Daenerys to suddenly turn with
the mention of the death of his family
is so powerful
Jon Snow figuring out he is a Targaryen
so the initial reaction in this whole
scene was great it's been set up for a
long time and we finally get to see the
payoff of John's reaction the only
downside from the scene is that it
changes John's character for the worse
he basically turns into a gern that
keeps repeating I don't want it and you
are more queen after this point but the
initial reaction was powerful it was
just done to death
Davos seeing Shireen 2.0 this was
another moment that came out of nowhere
and hits you in the heart because of the
girls semblance to Shireen it was a
great addition because it reminds us of
Davos his past relationship the only
unfortunate thing is that she doesn't
come back in the Battle of Winterfell
while the Crypt is getting rolled by the
undead it's just a great scene with
setup that doesn't have pay off later on
the entire wine and chill scene this
whole scene was great
we have Tyrion and Jaime talking about
how they evolved and changed
we have tormund hitting on Brienne and
we also have him drinking Giants milk
we have Brienne of Tarth [ __ ] smiling
Podrick singing oh my god I can barely
contain myself we can all agree that
Podrick singing is easily the best part
of season 8 when the Dothraki seemingly
get wiped out although it's completely
idiotic for the Dothraki to charge
head-on into the enemy it was still a
good moment the whole notion that the
entirety of the Dothraki force getting
rolled into one minute reintroduces how
vicious and dangerous the white Walker
army is it sets the stakes that everyone
is screwed and it will take a miracle to
survive to me it's great setup with
obviously not so great payoff Arya being
a badass on the wall although it's
shrouded in darkness
this is ironically one of the only fight
scenes we get that they don't cut away
from or use any crazy jarring editing
this is the only time in the season that
Aria kicks ass and I guess we can just
take whatever we can get at this point
the relationship between Arya and the
Hound this is the one thing that I wish
we got more of these two characters have
both changed so much it would have been
interesting to see their new dynamic but
instead they just teleported King's
Landing like everyone else and we go
from this character interaction no no
they give me to die again if I got hurt
- this character interaction you come
with me
you die here it just feels like a big
gap and they left stuff out Tyrians
goodbye to Jaime alright for this point
I am definitely not including Jaime
saying he didn't care for the public of
King's Landing [ __ ] light that [ __ ]
on fire the portion after that moment
where Tyrion says goodbye to Jaime and
how he wouldn't have survived if it
weren't for him is really emotional and
we barely see Tyrion breakdown this much
it is a little unfortunate that by this
point people feel disconnected with
Tyrion because of his deterioration the
shot of Danny being a dragon this is
just a very quick moment but everyone
was impressed by that shot we basically
all went like this and we're like whoa
cool and then we went back to that
neutral state of not knowing how to
react to the finale Danny getting to
touch the Iron Throne
this was another well-done moment the
music swelling the payoff of Daenerys
winning her reaction just this whole
moment gives you a goosebumps
bran of Tarth changing Jaime's deeds to
me this was my favorite moment in all of
the finale ironically it gives you an
actual resolution to Jaime's character
in a relationship between him and
Brienne it's a very feel-good moment and
it's hard to take it as she with it the
only issue is that she didn't let the
[ __ ] ink dry Jon paedon ghost after
the abysmal goodbye to ghost in Episode
four we're all go Scott was a glance
everyone was ready to revolt
luckily they redeemed themselves and
what was probably just a reshoot ghost
deserves much better but at least we got
a pet out of Jon